60 minutes exposed the deep divisions
that linger among Americans nearly a
year after the presidential election in
her debut last night as a 60 minute
special contributor Oprah Winfrey
traveled to Michigan to moderate a
heated focus group in a portion you will
see only on CBS this morning
when four spoke with one participant
about debating freely finding common
ground and securing the border the
biggest thing that maybe we've we've
started to lose an American what were
the what is the biggest danger to the
Republic is we've lost the ability to
debate freely to sit down and have
intense passionate rational debates and
you know what people may have feelings
hurt and we may really not like each
other when we're done but when we stop
having that ability when we lose the
ability to debate ideas the Republic is
over is there a way for us all to reach
some kind of common ground where all
sides can be heard and that is possible
and if we could do that at this table
why isn't it possible for Congress well
the thing is if Oprah if I want to sell
you a bushel of apples for $20 and you
only want pay me ten it does me no good
if I say no the price is 20 and I walk
back to my truck and it does you no good
if you say well I'm only willing to pay
10 at some point we have to come
together and figure out how we're gonna
get to $15 at some point twelve and
that's what bothers me about Congress is
you've got people over here saying no
way ever and you've got people saying no
way ever when you have conversations
with people you take the hot-button
issues off the table you look for the
common ground you look for the common
denominator and then you work from there
how many workers the day after our table
top talk we visited fourth-generation
farmer Jeff vanderwerff and one of his
orchards outside Grand Rapids what did
you think of our discourse last night
what did you think of all that you know
I thought it was I thought it was really
good really interesting discussion um
got to visit with a lot of people that I
wouldn't normally act interact with in
my day to day life really uh so it was
um it was eye-opening we were talking
last night about whether or not your
Congress gets you whether or not the
gets you do you think most of America
gets what it takes to do what you do out
here every day unfortunately I believe
the vast majority of Americans really
have no clue what it takes to do a lot
of what we do out here I mean everything
you see behind us all these apples are
hand-picked every Apple in the United
States is hand harvested there are no
machines for this so we depend on
migrant labor on skilled migrant labor
to come in and do this we have had over
the years dozens of American you know
domestic American citizens show up and
say yeah I'd like to pick apples most of
them don't make it through a day so how
are the immigration laws of gonna affect
you being able to get workers to do this
personally I think we probably ought to
let more people into this country at
some point but we have to have a handle
on who's coming in when they're coming
in where they're coming from all these
things so if President Trump were here
right now what would you advise him
about immigration I would advise the
president to continue the path to
securing the border because we have to
have a secure national border does that
mean building the wall I think it does
mean building a wall but it has to be a
wall with as he said during his campaign
I think it was a big beautiful door in
it or something to that effect
we need immigrant workers come into this
country for a variety of skills and
positions and we allow them to come in
and to fill jobs that we have here boy I
really liked that interview and I really
thought Jeff gave a very important
perspective about people who are doing
hard work on the front lines of
agriculture and other things that really
know running a business picking apples
by hand that perspective is incredibly
important yeah he's sure he really did
showed sort of understanding both sides
no question and seaching he can common
ground I thought it was interesting to
see all the passion around the table
last night watching it and I liked what
Jeff also said that we have to be able
to have passionate rational conversation
in this country and so many times we
don't do that it's just anger and you
don't hear the other person speaking and
we saw that last night yeah